Doutor quais outros suplementos devem
ser tomados com vitamina D3 quando se
trata de suplementação com vitamina D3 é
importante considerar outros nutrientes
que podem complementar os seus
benefícios e garantir uma absorção ótima
então aqui vão alguns suplementos que
podem ser tomados junto com a vitamina
D3 primeiramente a K2 a famosa K2 é um
complemento essencial porque ela ajuda a
direcionar o Cácio pros ossos e dentes
em vez de permitir que esse cálcio se
acumule lugar errado como artérias e
outros tecidos então isso vai reduzir o
risco de calcificação vascular outro
suplemento importante para usar junto
com a D3 É o cálcio se você tiver
indicação de utilizar por exemplo se
você tem alguma deficiência desse
mineral especialmente para aqueles que
buscam fortalecer os ossos de modo geral
a maioria das pessoas não t deficiência
de cálcio na dieta então isso tem que
ser analisado com muito cuidado e tem
que ser equilibrado com magnésio ok
também é crucial garantir que esse
cálcio esteja sendo absorvido e
utilizado de maneira adequada então
geralmente você usa ele em conjunto com
a D3 e a K2 o magnésio ele é fundamental
PR os ossos Ele trabalha em conjunto com
a vitamina D3 Ele regula a absorção de
cálcio ele ajuda a manter a saúde óssea
então magnésio é essencial para muitas
funções corporais incluindo a regulação
do Ritmo cardíaco e função muscular
ômega-3 que eu sempre falo aqui ele é
sempre valioso ele não tá diretamente
relacionado à absorção de vitamina D3
mas os os ácidos grassos omega-3 o Epa e
o dha são importantes pra saúde
cardiovascular e cerebral e é
interessante tomar conjunto com a
vitamina D3 porque é uma gordura então
ajuda a absorver e processar essa
vitamina então você pode tomar omega3
com a vitamina D3 e a K2 eles tomados em
conjunto vai ser bem interessante Além
disso manter uma dieta rica em frutas
vegetais grãos integrais proteínas
saudáveis gorduras saudáveis além de uma
hidratação adequada é crucial para
absorção e uso eficaz de nutrientes faça
exercícios regulares Uma Vida Saudável
ISO tudo vai contribuir paraa saúde
geral e eficácia dos Suplementos e
sempre consulte um profissional de saúde
de preferência dois né o nutricionista e
o médico ok